[Musica]
quando parlo qualcuno di Bitcoin le
reazioni sono sempre tra le più
disparate
abiti a quella moneta che serve a
comprare armi e droga nel Dark web vero
Oppure Ah si Bitcoin ho sentito dire che
inquina tantissimo Ci sta rovinando il
pianeta vi dico la verità a volte sento
addirittura qualcosa di positivo del
tipo Ah bello Bitcoin Ma come faccio a
diventarci ricco anch'io solo quando il
prezzo sale succede di solito Toglietemi
una curiosità quanti di voi hanno
sentito almeno una volta parlare di
Bitcoin In uno di questi modi alzate la
mano
immaginavo tantini C'è talmente tanta
diffidenza e timore nei suoi confronti
che anche le nostre stesse istituzioni
tendono a ripudiarlo l'anno scorso ho
aperto la mia società verso la quale
ricevo spesso pagamenti in criptop per
fare tutto per bene e inquadrare
l'attività Mi sono rivolto a banche
commercialisti avvocati Dovevate vedere
che faccia hanno fatto non è una cosa
tanto ben vista lei sarebbe un cliente
ad alto rischio non so se vogliamo
intraprendere questo rapporto Qualcuno
addirittura è arrivato a dirmi guarda in
Italia una cosa del genere non si può
proprio fare Ero arrivato a tanto così
dall'andarmene davvero cosa che mi
dispiaceva seppur nel mio piccolo io ci
tenevo a creare una realtà dei posti di
lavoro nel settore cripto qua in Italia
per fortuna dopo un pellegrinaggio non
indifferente ho trovato i giusti partner
e sono riuscito a partire Ma ragazzi che
fatica
questi pregiudizi purtroppo
distolgono molto l'attenzione da quello
che è il reale scopo il reale valore di
Bitcoin
Bitcoin nasce come strumento di libertà
Libertà
di poter detenere valore senza che
nessuno te lo possa confiscare
libertà di poter trasferire Tale valore
istantaneamente in tutto il mondo senza
terze parti che possono congelarti il
conto censurarti le transazioni decidere
cosa puoi fare con i tuoi soldi e cosa
no Libertà infine dalle politiche
monetarie scellerate di quei paesi che
flagellano i risparmi dei loro cittadini
a colpi di iperinflazione
non dobbiamo andare molto lontano per
renderci conto dell'importanza di uno
strumento simile durante il conflitto
Russia Ucraina quest'ultima ha permesso
di inviarle le donazioni in cripto la
risposta è stata pazzesca decine di
milioni di dollari in controvalore Sono
stati inviati da tutto il mondo con
ricezione quasi istantanea nessun cambio
di valuta nessuna transazione respinta
nessun giorno lavorativo da aspettare
per la credito nessuna commissione di
intermediari vari tutto il mondo ha
avuto la possibilità di partecipare
concretamente ad una causa che sentiva
sua
incluso il cittadino di quel paese del
terzo mondo che non ha accesso ai
servizi bancari
in Canada durante la crisi pandemica è
avvenuto un altro pesante attacco alla
libertà individuale chi protestava le
contromisure del governo per arginare il
covid si è ritrovato con i conti bancari
congelati e lo stesso valeva per le
persone a lui vicine
se qualcuno gli aveva fatto un
versamento per offrirgli un pranzo a
fargli un regalo rischiava di trovarsi
anch'esso il conto bloccato Questo Prova
che i circuiti finanziari sono sempre
più utilizzati come un'arma uno
strumento di controllo ed è quindi di
importanza Vitale avere un'alternativa
che ci permetta di sottrarci a tutto ciò
è un nostro diritto
so cosa state pensando ma così non è che
si rischia davvero che le attività
illegali abbiano via libera uno
strumento così potente In effetti se
finisce nelle mani sbagliate può
sicuramente fare danni proprio per
questa ragione È fondamentale che in
parallelo si muovano le regolamentazioni
Ma nella giusta direzione
occorre concentrarsi sul minimizzare gli
usi malevoli gli usi criminali di questa
tecnologia ma nel contempo preservare la
privacy e i diritti degli utenti in
buona fede pensate che lo stesso Bitcoin
ci viene in aiuto
l'infrastruttura su cui viene transato
la blockchain è trasparente ed
immutabile e con l'aiuto di appositi
software si riesce a tracciare tutti i
movimenti eseguiti I criminali lo sanno
e prediligono altri mezzi
ha pubblicato un report che lo dimostra
si tratta di un'azienda che di mestiere
faccia in analisis quelle analisi che
dicevo poco fa sulle transazioni su
blockchain quindi conosce bene il
fenomeno secondo tale report che si può
trovare facilmente online la parte di
transazioni legate aillecito
su tutti transati in criptovaluta nel
2021 è lo 0,15%.
torniamo ora al secondo grande mito
preferito dai detrattori il fatto che
Bitcoin nella rovina del nostro pianeta
partiamo da un presupposto al mondo ogni
cosa consuma energia in cambio di un
beneficio un privilegio che ci viene
dato prendiamo in esempio gli aerei che
ci permettono di viaggiare in qualunque
posto nel mondo in un anno consumano
4000 terra d'attora gli impianti di
condizionamento nei soli Stati Uniti per
mantenere al fresco o al caldo i
cittadini ne consumano 6.300 il settore
finanziario ne consuma 5.000 sapete
quanto consuma il mining di Bitcoin A
livello mondiale
250 terrawattora pari allo 0,16%
dell'energia che produciamo
non voglio minimizzare so che non è poca
Ma in cambio di cosa la consumiamo in
cambio di un protocollo sicuro
decentralizzato e Libero sul quale
vengono transati miliardi di dollari al
giorno senza alcun intermediario non è
che magari ne vale la pena
ogni anno il consumo energetico mondiale
aumenta in media tra l'1 e il 2%. il
progresso tecnologico implica anche
questo
minimizzare gli sprechi è pertanto una
nostra responsabilità ma cosa vuol dire
questo
questo significa non mettere il
condizionatore a 20 gradi tenere aperte
le porte del negozio quando fuori ce n'è
significa incentivare il rinnovo
periodica Di apparecchiature industriali
elettrodomestici e tutti quegli
strumenti che consumano energia verso
degli equivalenti a maggiore efficienza
significa incentivare il miglioramento
della classe energetica degli edifici
potrei andare avanti ore ma prendersela
con un industria che porta un valore
incommensurabilmente più alto del suo
consumo energetico Mi spiace ma
significa non aver compreso il problema
il secondo luogo bisogna riflettere
sulle fonti da cui proviene tale energia
è necessario incentivare il rinnovabile
per minimizzare l'impatto ambientale il
mining è attualmente una delle Industrie
con il maggior impiego di energia da
fonti rinnovabili pari al 58%, dato che
migliora Anno dopo anno ma vi dirò di
più il mining è un incentivo a investire
nella produzione di energia rinnovabili
poiché un eccesso di tale produzione può
essere facilmente convertito in valore
in Bitcoin vi racconto questa storia in
Texas c'è un problema di sbilanciamento
tra domanda e offerta dell'energia
questo spesso causa durante i picchi di
consumo dei blackout in alcune aree
urbane
costruire nuove centrali è un costo
notevole Considerando che per buona
parte dell'anno l'eccesso di energia
sarebbe o svenduto o peggio ancora mai
capitato secondo il governatore
investire nell'industria del mining
potrebbe risolvere questo problema
dirottando gli eccessi di produzione
verso i Miner che di fatto li
trasformano in Bitcoin che vi ricordo
sono convertibili in pochissimo tempo in
valuta in questo modo diventa una sorta
di Volano energetico e questo ricavo può
essere utilizzato per costruire nuove
centrali o altre infrastrutture tutto
con energia pulita
parlare di Bitcoin senza esserci mai
entrati in contatto senza capirlo
appieno e senza averlo mai utilizzato è
una fallacia in cui ahimè cadono in
tanti in questo modo si finisce per
ragionare per sentito dire per spargere
a macchia d'olio falsi miti su una
tecnologia che si può far paura Ma che
sono convinto diventerà la spina dorsale
di un nuovo sistema finanziario più
inclusivo e più equo che abbraccerà
tutto il mondo già lo sta facendo
guardatevi intorno per questa ragione
stasera provo a lasciarvi con un invito
quando tornate a casa provate ad
acquistare una piccola somma di Bitcoin
pochi euro mi raccomando non fatevi
prendere la mano
create il vostro Wallet il primo
contenitore di valore che è veramente
vostro e che nessuno vi può toccare
Provate a fare un trasferimento una
transazione e osservatene immediatezza e
semplicità probabilmente la farete con
una persona vicino a voi ma riflettete
sul fatto che potreste farla con
chiunque ovunque esso si trovi il tutto
senza nessun intermediario e nessuna
interferenza sono sicuro che per molti
di voi questo basterà scatenare la
curiosità quella scintilla quella voglia
di approfondire studiare e finalmente
così riusciremo a lasciarci alle spalle
questi luoghi comuni Quindi vi prego
fatelo
Grazie per l'attenzione